salut Jerrica Benton et vivre la vie la moins
exceptionnelle, procurez-vous un de ces
sacs d'épicerie ma sœur Kimber et moi vivons
avec notre tante Bailey et ses deux
enfants adoptifs qu'elle voit une de vos chaussettes
je n'aime pas être devant la caméra à un
moment donné nous  tous souhaitent que nous puissions simplement
devenir quelqu'un d'autre Je vais te jouer une
chanson que j'ai écrite qui a le cœur d'un
chasseur battant comme Sun elle me remerciera plus
tard
chérie banane il se passe quelque chose
dont tu as vraiment besoin pour voir ce qu'est oh mon
dieu  que moi avez-vous fait ça Kimber
c'est à propos de vous ne passerez pas toute votre
vie à vous demander ce qui se serait passé
si vous n'aviez pas pris cette chance la
plus grande maison de disques du monde
veut nous signer veut continuer
bienvenue dans les entreprises starlight c'est
Rio salut les filles vous n'êtes plus la
gemme Derica c'est comme ça que nous vous appelons maintenant cela
signifie changer votre façon d'agir le son et
regardez c'est nous
non c'est Photoshop tout le web a
parlé de sa salle de gym et son fan de
sœurs révélant un tout nouveau loo  k
non oh mon dieu ton oncle n'aurait jamais
deviné que venir ici signifierait un
tout nouveau Jerrica
tu veux dire des joyaux le monde entier veut
savoir qui tu es en ce moment une icône n'est
pas l'une des quatre c'est unique en son genre tu
ne le fais pas  je veux plus de nous
c'est toute ma famille qui est censée agir
ce n'est que le début
apporte moi qu'ils veulent juste moi c'est
écrit dans ces murs même quand les
chances semblent impossibles tu dois faire confiance
aux personnes dont tu es le plus proche je dois
réparer  c'est donc la synergie Junsu Showtime
tout le monde a une identité secrète
laquelle est la vraie yo
ma fille me tuerait si je ne faisais pas
d'autographe bien sûr elle va paniquer
sur ton bras ouais quand son nom utilise mais
Stephen